just as a gut check we're doing this
when we speak to 2022 candidates and
it's a weird question to ask but i hope
you'll indulge me
who is the real president of the united
states right now
well who's sitting in the white house
that's the that's you know that's joe
biden right was he there legitimately i
don't know let's find out i'm the i'm on
a lawsuit that's at the ninth circuit
court of appeals right now our oral
arguments will begin september 23rd and
we're asking to forensically audit 13
counties in california most important
lawsuit in the nation is it and i want
to get to the bottom of this question
because people go he's not legit he is
legit it was stolen it wasn't stolen
folks nobody knows well hold on a second
mike let's see if we can break that down
though because
so nobody knows we have we have results
from california right the results from
california are
biden got 11.1 million votes trump got
six million votes overwhelming victory
for buy those are the results we have in
order to say we don't know
we should have some reason to question
those results what reason do you have to
question the results that make you say i
can't be confident that we have the real
numbers
well david if you were an olympian and
you ran a race and you got the gold
medal let's say you're like usain bolt
you ran this race you got the gold medal
yep what's the first thing they do after
you set that world record
they do a blood test okay and they they
check to see if you have performance
enhancing drugs in your system okay
that's an audit they do an audit of your
bloodstream
why don't we do the same thing with the
greatest race in the world which is the
us presidential election well i think
one reason would be
just the voter registration numbers in
california are so lopsided towards
democrats that it's very hard to believe
that there would be any real outcome
there other than biden easily winning i
mean let me ask you a question
what do you suspect were the real
results in california
i don't know okay no but see but it's a
cop-out to say you don't know what
reason do you have to question the
results
thousands and thousands of affidavits
that have been submitted to my
co-plaintiff
under you know they notarized and uh you
know the charge of perjury if you lie on
this that they saw things that were not
right conducted in a myriad of places
including the polling places including
ballot drop-off boxes
nobody knows and yet no one wants to
look and all i'm asking with my
co-plaintiffs says let's open the hood
and let's actually see what occurred
okay
when you look at the voter registration
numbers
even if there were
tens of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands of these instances right
california only 24 of registered voters
are republicans there's just no way
trump could have won
well i'm not i'm not saying that i'm
saying that did you know this okay there
are
there are 2.8 million
more registered voters in california
than there are citizens no that is
absolutely untrue
i we've got the data to prove it i hope
you'll send it to me my co-plaintiff is
the election integrity project
california okay and then well listen
because i don't have i mean
i've not seen that i mean send it to me
send it to me you know every state in
which it has been claimed that there are
more voters than citizens it has been it
has been debunked and it seems in
california it wouldn't be even close has
any state done a forensic audit well the
states have done
all sorts of evaluations and recounts
and audits but then someone always hold
on mike hold on hold on hold on hold on
yes go ahead someone then comes along
and says that's not the type of audit i
meant
no they've done recounts nobody has done
an audit in arizona and audit was done
and it found biden got even more votes
the the arizona audit was not done
properly
what we're looking for is this we have
three things in our complaint yeah
here's the ballot i want to look at the
envelope and then let's look at the
machine okay they've had to look at the
m they've safeguarded the images of the
them the hard drives we have the voter
rolls
and let's compare all four of those all
right well let's do that we're not going
to be able to do it today so in the
interest of we could start today no i
mean you and i won't be able to now
listen i want to ask you something
there's this guy who we my audience
knows him as mike pillow he's the ceo of
my pillow mike lindell but as a
shorthand we'll sometimes call him mike
pillow or even just pillow everybody
knows who he is
he is obsessed with the machines and he
actually wants to sue every machine
are you where are you on the machines
well i think the machines need to be
looked at okay i think just like the
nest desousa's movie with uh 2000 mules
the ballot drop-off boxes need to be
looked at
um
one of the one of the areas in our
lawsuit is the article 4 section 4 of
the u.s constitution it's called the the
guarantee clause
and the federal government is supposed
to guarantee that we are free from
foreign invasion but it doesn't say how
the foreign invasion is conducted and
right now we have no safeguards in
california election law
to say china can't submit 30 million
ballots and we have no way to safeguard
against it when they under the guise of
covet have removed all the safeguards in
place but mike do you have reason to
believe china submitted 30 million
ballots it's very easy to say
i can't prove to you that it wasn't done
you can't prove to me it wasn't done but
do you have reason to believe china
submitted 30 million ballots i've seen
no such evidence i i don't need the
evidence i have the constitution which
says
any law that allows china to do this
is unconstitutional
because it allows for foreign invasion
whether it's at the ballot box or the
shoreline how can china submit
30 million ballots
when you have to be an american citizen
in order to even register to vote how is
that even possible
because you can do it through the ballot
boxes no verification needed in
california you can have same-day voter
registration
you don't have to vote you can literally
walk in on november 8th and say i've
never voted in my life before and i'd
like a ballot right but if you're
walking in and voting that then you're
an american citizen who who is
registering to vote how is china doing
that they can do it at the bet they can
do it through the boxes the drop-off
boxes see they can't deny any ballot
they receive
up until the close of business november
8th right but then they look at it and
if it's not a registered if it's not a
if it's not a citizen then it's an
invalid background how do they know it's
not a citizen there's no checks in place
you don't know they're not even allowed
to ask for id
they don't know if you're a citizen and
non-citizen in california this is the
thing but mike mike mike
there were 17 million votes in
california okay just just hear out the
numbers there were 17 million votes in
california biden got 11.
trump got six
when you talk about any one ballot box
and you talk about china and 30 million
ballots and on and on
even if i grant you that every one of
your thousands of affidavits is bona
fide proof of some fraud right bona fide
proof
when the popul when the voting public is
only 17 million people
how on earth do you think that they're
going to be able to slip by this number
of fraudulent fake whatever votes and
only a few thousand people submit
affidavits it but it's impossible to
believe that well then would you join me
in calling for an audit of the system so
i i see no reason to audit this there's
just the numbers don't add up there's no
reason to audit it
no if you won the gold medal we would
automatically audit the race okay well
there should be olympic olympic hundred
meter dash is not voting do you have no
i mean mike that doesn't make any sense
it sounds silly it makes total sense
because any competition in the united
states if tom brady uses an under fl
inflated football yeah we almost tear
the country apart why don't we do that
for the greatest competition in the land
this sounds so silly though mike it
sounds silly i don't know that this is
going to win you the 35th district i'm
not sure
well i'm not trying to to you know
please somebody i'm trying to say let's
get to the bottom of this issue so that
we can all be comfortable with u.s
elections once again most people are
comfortable that's the thing when you
poll people most people are comfortable
no that's not true what poll do you have
to suggest that well
the poll of my district and i can i can
show you that by the amount of people
who wait to go to the polling locations
because they don't trust that's not a
poll mike most people just vote on
election day that doesn't mean they
don't trust another system